all right this is the second video where
we're gonna talk about you know how we
got the data that we did how we analyzed
it and you know some other factors that
just didn't make it to the main video
but just FYI this isn't the main video
that's on the regular coffee break
channel go check that out the first link
in the description below you go watch
that first before you watch this okay so
how do we collect this data so as I sort
of mentioned in the first video this
data was scraped using a bot using the
YouTube data API it was done by Mitchell
jolly it was scraped at the same time
every day 9:00 a.m. GMT I believe hey
future Steven here I'm trying to throw
this video together and I realized that
I forgot to tell you a few things about
this so the first thing is how this is
structured it's a unique video in that
I'm trying to structure it sort of like
with a table of contents in mind because
I know a lot of you don't want to go
through this whole thing so in the pin
comment I'm gonna leave timestamps to
the questions that I'm answering at
different periods of time and this video
also if you think of anything that I
didn't cover please leave comments in
the description I'd be happy to answer
some questions the other thing that I
didn't really talk about really how you
can get your hands on this stuff so I
want to cover that for a second here so
if you'll notice that this is what we're
now talking about okay how you can get
your hands on this data is there are
three components you need to remake this
data set we did and first you need
Mitchell jollies original data set so if
you go to Kaggle there's the link link
in the description his cattle profile
you can just download all the CSV or
JSON files and you can get started there
okay
the second thing you need is might
youtuber classification which was
crowd-sourced it's in a CSV file as well
go ahead and get that that has all the
unique channels that trended with what
their classification is some of them
were classified as n/a just so you know
because we couldn't find the channel or
something like that
I think that's less than 1% of the data
set though and then the third thing you
need is our jupiter notebook which
contains all the code to to run the
analysis in the way that we did if
you're interested in doing your own work
you don't need that but if you want to
see if you want to redo the work for
yourself that's what you need now
an important part of that is there is
you need to assign the path to to
wherever you're storing your files so
again there should be a link in the
description for how to download all our
files there but you need to make sure
there's a part where it says you know
your path here or something like that
you need to go ahead and put in your
file path in order so it accesses that
other than that everything else should
run as planned so that's pretty much it
I'm gonna get back to you know talking
about all the all the limitations of
this data set all the things we did all
the things that I think about it but
didn't make it to the main channel but I
just needed to get that off my chest and
as far as I know there's only one hole
in the data set as far as like the
collection of it
I think Mitchell jolly told me that he
had gone away and when he came back for
like part of his seven months five days
were missing okay so that's like the
only hole in data set but other than
that this is this is by far and away the
most data-driven look at the training
tab we've ever had and I don't think
those five days that we're missing is
really too impactful but there are some
limitations to this data set that are
worth mentioning okay so first and
foremost I think the most subjective
part of this whole thing that you
probably may want answers to is is the
data classification right so I
classified every single channel as being
a part of some kind of category whether
that be a youtuber traditional media a
movie channel trailer music traditional
viral etc and these were somewhat
subjective categories that I created to
try to capture the answer of you know
how often does traditional media trend
and how is it rewarded etc but these
definitions are somewhat arbitrary and I
can see people disagreeing with some of
them as well as the fact that some
channels sort of fall in the cracks of
like which do they really belong to like
Anthony Fantana for example I can see
some people thinking oh he's a music
channel but at the same time he's sort
of a youtuber and so you have to make
certain calls about like well is he more
into like the music side or but he's
also like his main things YouTube so how
do you think about that how do you think
about someone who's reviewing music so
we classified him
youtuber by the way but my point is
there's a small margin of error that's
just necessarily gonna be part of any
classification that is somewhat based on
subjective definitions so I posted the
Excel CSV with all crowd-sourced
classifications all available so anyone
can publicly critique them I don't mind
anytime you're doing some primary
research like this people are gonna
disagree especially when some of it's
subjective so I just wanted to make that
publicly available so people could see
sort of what's going on that's gonna be
linked below and another thing that I
think could have introduced some error
is just the 70 people I use to
crowdsource this data it was too much to
classify myself and I didn't have enough
people interested in classifying to have
a second round of people double-checking
the first groups work ideally that's
what it would have happened I just
didn't have enough interest on the
second channel maybe after this video
people will be more interested in
working on crowdsource projects like
this but that's a limitation of the data
set final limitation of the data set is
that look this is a very limited window
of time this is from November 2017 to
June 2018 is it the best look of the
training time we've ever had yes but do
conclusions that were from history based
on a year ago are they relevant to today
I would argue that they are but you
can't draw that strong of conclusions so
what I want to say here is that I'm
aware that the algorithm changes I'm
aware that it's dynamic so just bear in
mind that the current state of affairs
could be very different from what the
state of affairs we saw a year ago you
know whatever now let's talk about data
visualization and analysis so one of the
first things we had to do with this data
set was we realized that a lot of videos
trend over multiple days so they would
show up multiple times in our data set
because the bots would pick him up you
know Thursday and then it also pick him
up Friday Saturday Sunday so we decided
to do was remove duplicates and we
remove them such that only the first
time it appeared on trending was what we
captured and collected that way we could
find out how many views did they have
when they first appeared on trending on
that note one of the assumptions we sort
of make is that all videos who appear on
trending their views when captured where
their views when they start a training
of course this is not exactly true a
video could have started trending at 12
a.m. and then
only been seen on our data set at 9:00
a.m. when it was collected so there's a
margin of error there as well I think
it's rather small but just be aware that
that happens it's plus or minus like 24
hours I guess of when our BOTS picked it
up versus when it was trending also
because we only collected once a day
there may be some videos that sort of
slip through the cracks just be aware of
that like if they got on at 10:00 a.m.
so our BOTS wouldn't have collected it
and they got off at 11:00 p.m. that
night we would have never seen that on
our data set so that's a limitation as
well but I don't see many solutions to
this other than collecting like every
hour on the hour and I think that's just
way too data intensive plus YouTube's
data API limits the number of requests
you can pull so I'm not even sure that's
a feasible project
I just wanted to state that this is a
limitation of our data set now let's
talk about data visualization so now
that we have our channels classified and
we have our unique values now what we
want to know is you know let's visualize
this in some meaningful way so what I
was interested in is like the channels
that are excelling so I decided to check
how many times is a channel trend like 0
10 15 20 whatever and then what's their
average views when we catch them on
trending so what's their barrier to
trending that's the graph you guys saw
in the first video but one thing I'll
note is that some videos were not
actually caught on that graph because
they were so high up in the y-axis
I think david dobrik for example like
wasn't on our dataset cuz he was at 17
million views before trending or
whatever and what was happening is our
our y-axis was so squished because it
was trying to account for these like for
these channels that were in the
stratosphere all of those channels like
only trend once or twice but we decided
to trim that side of the axis because we
realized okay it's gonna limit the your
ability to even see visually what what
else is going on here if we include that
so we trimmed some outlier examples
only-- on the y-axis just to make the
data more readable that's just something
I've got to be upfront about one thing
that I don't think I mentioned in the
main video we also size the bubbles
according to how many subscribers they
had that was like a cool way of trying
to find out does the number of
subscribers you have make it harder for
you to trend like does the number of
scribers you have mean that you need
more views before you get on training
and the answer to that turns out to be
no because we see all those traditional
media like ESPN CNN The Colbert Fallon
Kimmel all of them have well into the
millions of views and they're trending
with only like 500,000 to a million
views so so clearly this does not
seriously impact your ability to trend
at low numbers but now let's talk about
some things that might drive trend
ability because I know in the video all
I talked about was views and obviously
there's a lot more that could drive
trend ability maybe you have your pet
hypothesis for why some people trend
some people don't and I tried to test a
few common common examples and common
thoughts to get an idea and none of them
really worked but let's run through them
anyway so one thing I thought was
interesting is does comments or likes or
dislikes some variable that's not views
have something to do with whether you
trend and the answer to that seems to be
no because what we find is that views
are highly correlated with all those
values so like if you get a certain
number of views you're really likely to
get some proportion maybe 10% of those
in likes 0.1% of them in dislikes you
know etc so if likes and comments and
dislikes were a factor they would just
be linked to views and we don't see
views as being too important of a factor
to predict if someone trends on that
note like when I say views don't matter
that much for training because I don't
think they do let me give you an example
okay so one channel that I found as an
example for this is The Associated Press
who have who trend with really low
numbers but what I found interesting is
a not just you know their numbers
because I thought well maybe they just
have a fast growth rate and they just
get on training early like maybe they
just get all their views really fast and
they jump on trending maybe it has
nothing maybe it's there's no conspiracy
whatever so here here's the Associated
Press the times they trend it's seven
times in total and what's weird is like
some of these like they trend with
literally less than a thousand views I
don't know if you can see that they
trend with less than at 748 videos when
they trended with the raw 7 South
Carolina deputies one officer shot they
turned to 748 videos but what's weird
about it and what I find strange is that
it was public
on the 16th so it shows what time it's
published 16th of what is that January
January 2018 but when it actually
trended was the 18th so it's it was two
days old two days old when it trends
with 700 views 748 views in two days and
it's on trend
that's what I mean like views don't seem
to matter in some instances for trin
ability because it's like people are
trending they're not trending till they
have 17 million views and some people
are trending when they have 700 views
over two days so it's it's really
bizarre honestly some of some of these
channels that are trending it's really
bizarre and theirs doesn't seem to be
any Silver Bullet that makes the answers
for all the facts the other kind of myth
or thought that I thought I'd test out
is whether the median number of views
that a channel gets has anything to do
with how many views they need to trend
my thought was I think even PewDiePie
echoed this thought but it was a thought
that I have that maybe like let's say
coffee breaks average video does 10,000
views maybe four coffee break to trend I
only need a hundred thousand views
because it's like ten fold YouTube
realizes I'm doing super well for my
channel so then they turn that video and
that would make up for the fact that
sometimes creators like PewDiePie he'll
get you know 10 million views on a video
and it won't trend and it's like why and
this could explain it because it would
be like oh well he always gets 5 million
views so really his videos only doing 2
times better than it normally does so to
test this I had a Twitter user who I
will link right here
use the YouTube data API again to go
ahead and pull the last 100 videos from
all the creators that we see on trending
and so the idea there would be like okay
let's check of their average views when
trending against how many views do they
normally get what's their median views
of about a hundred videos it took like a
hundred videos for a sample size and we
took the ratio and my hope was that
you'd see consistently like a video has
to do 10 times better than its normal
performance than a channels normal
performance for it to trend
unfortunately there was no relationship
here at all you had a ratios of a
hundred like videos I do a hundred times
better you have ratios of 0.5 we're like
the
doing half as well as it's normal normal
comparison video and it's training so
there doesn't seem to be any
relationship there that was confusing I
thought that would for sure be like a
really good insight the final thing that
I thought of was I know YouTube often
parrots the line that hey we're not
checking out what's trending on YouTube
were checking out what's churning around
the world so my thought was maybe we can
check Google Trends which shows you how
often a certain keyword gets searched
and we can check that and we can say
okay if something's getting searched a
lot it's more likely to trend so for
this I checked out the channel
refinery29 which is sort of a an outlier
in our project it trended about 40 times
over a very specific window of time
about three months it was very strange
trending circumstances so I thought okay
let's check out the Google Trends
searches for refinery29 and when you do
that unfortunately we don't get a great
take care because they Trin it about
between November when we first saw them
start to trend but and then we saw them
trend to about March in that time frame
we don't see them search that often on
Google and so my conclusion all I only
did a very preliminary look at this kind
of thing I didn't see a strong
relationship with a channel being like
super likely to train it turns a whole
lot I didn't see a relationship between
that and then being searched a lot more
on Google now all of this being said I
know that a lot of you are sort of gonna
be like oh you could have done so much
more there's so much more to explore
here and to that I totally agree this
was a preliminary research at best and I
look forward to passing the baton on to
other people who can do further research
into this I didn't want to dive too deep
into the Nitty Gritty of what some
sometimes I think my audience isn't too
interested in but I did want to get a
good glimpse of like just so I could
understand how does trending work but
I'm not gonna pretend that this is the
end-all be-all take on this obviously
YouTube's promised to change their
algorithm obviously there's a lot more
work to do here especially in other
countries so I kind of pass it off to
you if you'd like to do more research in
this I left my Jupiter notebooks which
has all the code to how all our graphs
were created as well as the fact that I
left
Michell jollies data set in the
description below so you have literally
everything you need to recreate all my
data my all my graphs all my data you
have all the data sets for all these
countries and you have the way to
basically generate these charts for any
country you so choose so if you're
youtuber out there you're looking for
something fun to explore I'd really
recommend you take on this topic I think
there's so much that I didn't cover
there's so much more to do here and I
just wanted to get the conversation sort
of rolling on this also I almost forgot
go check out Ryan Hunter's website Fair
trending let me show you that right now
Fair trending is a website which is an
objective ranking of the most popular
videos you can if you go to the learn
more it explains exactly how it does it
it's a transparent algorithm which is
really cool I found to be really neat
and yeah it was it was made by Ryan
Hunter I talked with him I asked him
some questions about training and he's
an amazing guy I know the site is still
being worked on but I'm really excited
to see what he does with this I think
this could be a really cool place for
for youtubers to go to see what's really
going on the other thing I want to talk
about is algo transparency this is a
website started by what's-his-name I
don't know how to say his name yet
gear made choiceless I'm so sorry man
did I butchered your name
he's an ex-googler who started this
website that's devoted to basically
figuring out how the recommended
algorithm works sort of through the
method of looking at black boxes that I
talked about which is because we don't
know exactly how it works instead we
just look at output and then start
making inferences with when we collect
enough data so this is a really cool
website this is just sort of on the in
line with thinking about YouTube
algorithms so check this out it will
show you how many channels are
recommending different parts of YouTube
and one of my favorite things is he
actually maps out a lot of oh man it's
so much dpi he maps out a lot of them of
how YouTube works like and what who's
being recommended to what and so this is
the music part this is cars but
basically basically you can see he's
tried to see what channel's reckon
what other channels so like popular MMO
is linked to FG TV which is linked to
gameplay which is linked dan dan the man
anyway
this is really cool stuff if if if you
like following people follow him on
Twitter or go check out his website algo
transparency org alright yeah amen
listen to the record space send him from
straight smacking of the ward I was on
the plane and the stewardess said that's
foolishness so for that beat I came with